what is our real reality as you know it
for me my dad died 20 years ago and I
started talking to him when I do a
reading I'm like can you hone their
energy can you focus them turn up their
volume and so he does that for me on the
other side we work in concert you also
have relatives on the other side who
feel connected to you that you might be
named after or you could have a a great
great aunt Sophie who was a rebel like
you who Vibes with you and and walks
with you so they connect to us in ways
that are on a soul level and they they
try and guide us there are also these
other guides who may have been in your
profession
who feel like in one lifetime they
didn't get everything out they wanted to
do and they'll help you if they Vibe
with you they'll help you so I could
have other mediums who lived who give me
their energy you could have race car
drivers from the past that Focus their
energy on you in moments of Panic or
down to the wire moments they talked to
us they guide us
they share their knowledge with us and
so there are many different entities on
the other side that if you're an active
Soul as we are they're there with you
and that can just be somebody trying to
Wrangle their five kids I mean that's an
active Soul too I just mean somebody who
is making connections emotionally out
there in the world and trying to leave
the world in a better place and for the
people who do nothing the world's worse
off for it you know if they had if I had
done nothing the Amber Alert wouldn't
have come out for another year or so you
know and then that whole year all the
kids that would have fallen between the
cracks if I hadn't been willing to take
it on the chin and go up against all the
Skeptics and I went up against all the
Skeptics very publicly and
um then
things wouldn't have changed mines
wouldn't have opened medium wouldn't
have come out if I hadn't been willing
to be studied by scientists and
published an academic journal what if I
sucked what if I was afraid of that what
if what if I scored low what happens
then I didn't let my head go there I
just did it I put it on the line This is
my talent this is what I can do if it's
not good enough I don't belong here in
this field and I was ready to go back to
law school is it important to connect
with other energies uh scented Masters
or Angels or anything like that I've
heard that they need you to ask them for
help for them to help so is that an
important is that could that be a really
helpful thing in life I've I've always
said that it's your intention you have
to State your intention to them what you
want what you need from them and as soon
as you do they'll deliver it for you
they want to be invited back into your
life so when I read my clients at the
end I say okay they want to be part of
your life still and they often talk
about you're not a you're not a
an orphan you know the the parents are
like you're not an orphan you still have
a mom you still have a dad and the kids
that come through say I'm still part of
the family I'm still part of the family
and they like stated and own it and they
need us to say we still want you in our
lives you know there's a place for you
at the table during the holidays your
ornaments high up on the tree and it
makes us smile and we love including you
in our lives and we're not holding them
here hostage it's not like that they
stay because without us their Heavens
not complete so they're waiting for us
because we are their Heaven that's why I
titled my second book we are their
Heaven because I noticed they kept
coming back to the living even though
they could be on the other side with all
the people that they miss they keep
coming back to their children or to
their parents because their their heaven
isn't complete without us so they go
back and forth between the worlds and
how special are we because we see
ourselves as so insignificant sometimes
how special are we that we're versions
of somebody's heaven like they show me
memories that they are reliving that
include the person that's still alive
being five years old and you know Mommy
carrying him from the wedding he was
just dancing in a little suit and
um and and he fell asleep on her
shoulder and that's her Heaven that's a
version of her heaven so throughout our
lives we're adding all of these
Beautiful Moments to lives that when our
physical bodies die is what we relive on
the other side so you're creating your
versions of Heaven here so you want to
make it good
don't suck come on and and I wish people
in the physical world would see on a
soul level how important they are to
those that that come through and say
um you you made me feel needed again you
know I love you and I have grandmothers
that are that felt more like that was
their child you know the grandchild
because they helped raise them and so
there's so there's like a soul mate
connection between grandmothers
sometimes in the grains it's just very
beautiful the strings are very glittery
and they're beautiful and they're thin
but strong and they connect us all
living and dead and I just I hope the
living wake up a little bit and put
themselves out there little bit more and
and and shine yeah for who they are does
that do those lives when they cross over
do they are they able to reincarnate and
still have that sort of timeline or that
reality like continue as a Continuum or
do they have to complete something
before they can reincarnate some don't
want to come back some already had their
perfect life and they stay with that
person and the people connected to them
on the other side there's nothing more
for them to achieve they've done
everything and they've come back time
and time again and they've got the Holy
Grail finally and they stay they stay
over there and they're like I'm blessed
and they live in that nature and then
they help other people in the physical
world
the people that didn't evolve they do
come back and there's something that
they actually agree on the other side
that they need to learn and that it
might be hard and they know what they're
going to go through but they say I can
do it I can handle it but then sometimes
they're given a body with a chemical
imbalance or some sort of challenge they
didn't foresee and it's up to them to
overcome it
it's hard to be human I'm sure you've
answered this many times and I don't
like to ask questions that you've
probably even asked before as much as
humanly possible but I do want to know
like what the most sort of common
message from the other side is to help
us to live a better life like what is it
that they want to tell us the the don't
live in fear one is a very big one that
they come through with and say take
risks be who you are
don't worry about me I know how much you
love me that's another big one there are
no goodbyes for the people that are hung
up over they didn't get to their dad's
bedside before he died or or their moms
or they weren't there with their child
when they died
there are no goodbyes so they're like
don't get hung up on that word
I'm still here we're still going to be
together and then when my dad died and
this helped me
I heard a voice and it's told me every
day you wake up is a good day
every day you wake up is a day closer to
seeing your dad again he's not your past
he's your present and future you're not
leaving him behind you're moving towards
him and then when I would get out of bed
the next day I recognized I was a day
closer to him and it it healed something
in me to know that and if it's
perspective we're actually moving
towards them why are we spending so much
time being sad they want us to take the
risk they didn't take in life they want
us to go on the trips that we say we'll
go in five years you know uh I don't
have the money now do what a 19 year old
would do wing it you know yeah get a
backpack find a cheap way don't stay at
the Ritz whatever but get there because
five years may not come for you and I
see that happen all the time so I do
stupid things like I wanted to eat Lucky
Charms in Ireland because I promised 11
year old Allison me that I would one day
when I was eating my I like your terms
I'm like I'm gonna go to Ireland I'm
going to eat Lucky Charms there and I
did and I rolled down a hill of clovers
so my list is maybe different than other
people but it brings me joy oh my God
it's all about I can't believe I didn't
have that one my last name is Patrick
you'd think I'd want to go eat Lucky
Charms in Ireland and Landon and find
the pot of gold at the end of the Clover
Hill that's what I'm talking about put
it on your list totally I made the silly
mistake of deciding that the only thing
on my bucket list was running a marathon
and that was just I don't know that's
not a common thing you can constantly
add to your list good good good I'm good
I drew a livingless not the dead list
this is the living this is the living
list things you want to take with you to
the other side these memories these
moments and I drink champagne
overlooking the Eiffel Tower with my
husband on Valentine's Day if you like
this clip and you want to hear the whole
episode click at the bottom of your
screen
all right